claims that Irish Jewish and traveler
people all suffer from racism they
undoubtedly experience Prejudice this is
similar to racism and the two words are
often used as if they are
interchangeable our correspondent
continues it is true that many types of
white people with points of difference
such as redheads can experience this
Prejudice but they are not all their
lives subject to racism the letter
concludes in pre-civil rights America
Irish people Jewish people and travelers
were not required to sit at the back of
the bus in apartheid South Africa these
groups were allowed to vote and at the
height of slavery there were no white
seeming people manacled on the slave
ships
[Music]
rights so a lot to unpick not least that
seeming comparison between people
picking on redheads and anti-Semitism
what about the idea that white seeming
people whatever that means cannot be the
victims of racism and yeah absolutely no
mention of the Holocaust whilst
referencing anti-jewish sentiment not
indeed the fact that the study quoted in
the article should Travelers and Jewish
people experience the greatest levels of
racism in the UK and so who was
responsible
former Shadow Home Secretary and
lifelong anti-racism campaigner labors
Diane Abbott herself black of course
despite an inevitable apology given
Labor's relationship with anti-Semitism
kierstormer has chosen to suspend her
from the party and her future in
politics hangs in the balance there's an
investigation going on at the moment
that's the right thing the whip has been
suspended that was done very very
swiftly and I have condemned what she
said along with many other people but
does mazab have a point or at least
something close to one is the hierarchy
of racism of which cure starmer
complains in fact a reality
I'm Neil Patterson and this is the Sky
News Daily
[Music]
today I'm joined by tamiwa oluwadi a
writer and the author of the original
Observer article to which Diane Abbott
was responding to me great to have you
on I mean I suppose we need to start
with Diane Abbott herself when you read
her letter her response to your article
what were your first thoughts my first
thoughts were a mixture of both surprise
and unsurprise
so I was surprised that she was willing
to
very publicly Express those views I
would understand if she expressed them
through a Facebook comment or like a
tweet like something that was thrown
away
but the fact that she would Express such
views through a letter sent to a
national newspaper surprised me
but I was also unsurprised because she
was merely articulating The Logical
conclusion of a set of what I would
consider
pseudo-progressive assumptions about
racism which is that racism is only
about Prejudice and power racism only
affects so-called people of color
and doesn't affect ethnic minority
people that are perceived as white so
yeah it was a mixture of both surprise
but also non-surprise
we'll delve into Dan Abbott's rationale
For What Little there may well be in in
just a second but just remind us the
article to which she was responding what
was the central thrust of it the
headline is in front of it at the moment
racism in Britain is not a black and
white issue it's it's far more
complicated yes so the initial Observer
article
that I wrote the week before Diane
Abbott's letter
was about trying to explain that racism
is not something that merely affects
black and brown people racism also
affects Jewish people in the UK Irish
communities in the UK and also traveler
and roma communities in the UK so we
need to be more nuanced and now we
understand racism and this was on the
back of a very long and comprehensive
report
that was recently released that found
that the ethnic minority groups that are
most likely to report
experience in racial abuse in the UK
are traveler communities and Jewish
people
the reports to me what it's referencing
is the evidence for equality National
survey conducted by researchers at
Oxford Glasgow and Manchester it claims
to have the most up-to-date and detailed
evidence on ethnic inequalities in the
UK including what its authors say is
unprecedented insight into the
experiences of gypsy traveler Roma and
Jewish people who reported the highest
levels of abuse
but to me another thing that I found
pretty interesting about the study was
that the difference in reported
experiences of racism between minority
groups that are often clearly wrongly
assumed to have similar experiences uh
take for example almost half of black
Caribbean Brits reporting having
experienced some sort of racist assault
but just over a third of black African
Brits reporting the same and I think
that that might partly be the fact that
what black Caribbean people consider
racism might be different to what black
African people consider him as well that
might be part of the story we don't know
yet the um reports are as a sufficiently
delved into that difference and I think
even more generally speaking what's the
Striking is that black Caribbean people
have a very different experience of
things like education in the UK to black
African people
so black Caribbean students in British
schools for example are more than twice
as likely to be excluded from schools
than black African pupils and black
African pupils tend to have a greater
GCSE and a-level attainments at schools
as well so if we look at the
institutions within our society the
experiences of even what we often refer
to as the black community there are
differences within that community
which I think needs to be acknowledged
if we genuinely care about the
inequalities in our society
let's focus on on the central complaint
that people had with with Diane Abbott's
letter which is this this idea that
white people cannot be the victims of
racism from her perspective and I
suppose the immediate counter to that is
that 60 of the traveler population 55 of
Jewish people have indeed experienced
racism and are at the top of the the
league table so to speak that is in this
research does that not suggest however
then that that hierarchy of racism that
kirstama talked about might actually
exist that there are groups who
experience more racism it's just not the
way around that Diane Abbott assumes it
to be yeah but with terms like
hierarchical racism I think we need to
be careful because there is a risk in
viewing racism as a sorts of competition
those are risk in June racism in that
way because that might encourage certain
ethnic minority groups to feel a degree
of Envy essentially that some minority
groups are getting more media attention
that some minority groups are getting a
greater degree of sympathy and I think
that any form of racism as I said
earlier deserves to be both condemned
but also to be challenged and we as a
collectives of society we need to
challenge racism as comprehensively as
possible but I think viewing it as this
sort of hierarchy I think that's
potentially dangerous because racism is
not a competition the fact that some
ethnic minority groups might experience
more racism possibly that might be
factually true but that doesn't mean
that other ethnic minority groups are
less deserving of anti-racist attention
but I think what that ABBA objected to
more than the figures or the statistics
is the fact that I essentially included
minority groups perceived to be white as
victims of racism understandably but
erroneously claim that that Abbott has
said that Jewish people and other ethnic
minority groups experience less racism
than black and brown people that's not
what she said she said Jewish people
traveler communities and Irish groups
cannot be victims of racism
come here I wonder what role the kind of
the concept of white privilege might
have played in bringing Diane Abbott to
write the letter but is that perhaps
what spread down Abbott into action the
idea that just by nature of my birth as
a white man the white man in this
conversation you know I enjoy privileges
that people who do not share my skin
tone do not is is that what has pushed
Dan Abbott into this into this
conclusion yes I think the position that
that Abbott eventually expressed and
that letter is a direct logical
conclusion of a very sort of simplistic
idea of white privilege because
or if we accept that white privilege
actually exists and if we accept that
Jewish people or Irish people or
traveler communities all of them are
white if we accept that
then by definition those groups are in
some sense privileged
those groups cannot be victims of racism
by definition and I think this is both
patently untrue because traveler
communities for example have the worst
educational outcomes out of all ethnic
minority groups in the UK and the notion
of of white privilege of course is
underpinned by the idea that white
people are privileged in terms of like
education employment and so forth it's
not just inaccurate but it's also
dangerous as well because one of the key
tropes of anti-Semitism is the idea that
Jewish people exercise disproportionate
power over the rest of society and if
Jewish people are white then ultimately
the conclusion that must be drawn is
that Jewish people are in some sense
privileged and that Segways vary
conveniently to the perception by
anti-semites that Jewish people exercise
power in society
[Music]
so do you think that in writing that
letter Diana was herself racist do you
think that she holds what we could
classify as as racist views you know
Diane Abbott as it's been reported often
over the past few days lifelong
anti-racism campaigner I mean herself
might might fall into that category I
think I I would incline more towards the
view expressed by the um author and
comedian David bediel the author of the
book Jews don't count and badille
recently argued that with Diane Abba
it's not a straightforward case of
racism it's more of a case of a ethical
blind spot to certain forms of prejudice
and what the deal have had in mind in
particular is anti-Semitism so it's not
a very straightforward case of Dan Abba
being an anti-sema it's more of a case
of her not viewing anti-Semitism or
something which is racist which is a
grave moral failing and so rights
essentially and I think what was also
striking about the letter was the fact
that she uses examples to illustrate her
points our Parkside South Africa
and Jim Crow America in response
to my column which was specifically
about
racism in the UK so I think another part
of the story is is the way in which
a very
american-centric conception of racism is
now seen as the main way or even the
only way with which we can understand
racism well that of course is what you
explored in your book this is not
America the idea that you know U.S ideas
about racism have really shaped the way
in which we think about the issue here
what is the negative impact of of
wholesale importing this view of racism
from the United States
it makes us unable to specifically focus
on the inequalities that
affects our society
so if we can't
properly understand the inequalities in
British Society then we can't change it
and it also means that we can't also
look at the differences and nuances
within the black community in the UK in
fact I I wouldn't even use a term like
black community I prefer black
communities for instance just just one
example the majority of black Americans
are descended from enslaved Africans
that were brought over from Africa to
the new world between the 17th and the
19th centuries whereas the majority of
black people in the UK are either
African immigrants or the children of
African immigrants many people still
think that the majority of black people
in the UK are black Caribbean people but
that's not true over the past 20 25
years there's been a huge influx of
migration from Africa which has
completely transformed the demographic
makeup of black British people but this
fascinating story hasn't been reported
sufficiently so I think my book and a
lot of the things I write about is about
trying to
specifically address what's going on in
the UK when it comes to race relations
because I think it's not only important
to do that to have a more nuanced and a
more truthful anti-racist politics but I
also think doing that gives a greater
degree of dignity to every black and
ethnic minority person and also to every
white person as well by looking at our
own culture history and politics judging
that and looking at it through our own
terms rather than through the
perspective of a foreign country
we certainly both do agree that black
community as a phrase is unnecessarily
reductive I think you could probably
argue black communities as well again it
doesn't give the full picture of the
diversity and the difference but I
wonder when I say the sentence
Britain is a racist country to you do
you identify that as valid as true or or
again perhaps unnecessarily reductive I
I would ask um could you be more
specific yeah that's the problem with
that phrase isn't it it's it's a
statement of fact but without any detail
because if you say that statement as
well then
that there's a risk in that statement
turning in through
a kind of banality because then you
could say well isn't that true of all
countries in the world
is there a country in the world that's
that's not racist
so so that's that's why I would ask what
what do you mean specifically and I
think one of the problems with this
inside discussion or discourse on race
is the lack of specificity and the utter
Reliance upon generalizations because
then we can't have a fruitful
conversation unless we are
specific in what we're talking about
because then we're just talking at Cross
purposes let's conclude with where we
started with with Diane Abbott herself
and of course she has made a very public
apology she has been suspended from the
party and though there will be an
investigation what ultimately would you
like to see happen as a conclusion to
this well personally speaking if Diane
Abbotts could show genuine Contrition
and by that I mean explaining
why she wrote what she wrote and why
she's now changed her mind
then the Christian values of forgiveness
and mercy with which I was raised would
incline me towards readmitting of her to
the labor party
but I also think that this is both a
morally and politically difficult things
with castama to do
because castama has recently outlined a
zero tolerance approach to anti-Semitism
and kestarma is now trying to rightly so
utterly distance himself from the labor
party and I also think realistically
abbots would not be able to offer that
kind of substantial apology so I think
realistically now starma has no option
other than to expel Dan Abbotts which
which I think is is a very sad outcome
because I have no personal animus or ill
will towards that another
but what she said especially after
starma has outlined a zero tolerance
approach than semitism what Abbott said
was totally unacceptable
great to have you on the daily podcast
thanks very much for joining us thank
you
my thanks to tomino owolati and of
course to you for listening to the Sky
News Daily with meet Neil Patterson this
Edition was produced by Rosie Gillett
with Alex Eden our editor is Philly
Bowman
[Music]